DAN FELD: Hi.
This is Dan Feld here
from Google Developers.
And we are here at Founder
World in San Francisco.
And with me today is Ted
Kraus from Tech-Rx Ventures.
Hi, Ted.
Thanks a lot for joining us.
TED KRAUS: Thanks for having me.
DAN FELD: I know that
we just finished up
your keynote upstairs and
went into the expo area.
So tell us a little
bit about your venture.
TED KRAUS: Absolutely.
So Tech-Rx is a
unique venture fund.
We invest in companies that
are struggling to scale.
So we typically
invest up to $250,000.
So that's the financial
capital piece.
And we also invest the human
capital piece to help correct
or turn around venture-backed
tech companies that
have hit some wall or they're
at some inflection point
and they need to be fixed.
So that's what we do.
DAN FELD: Would
you say that lots
of startups that reached
a point that they have
some kind of a traction
in trying to scale,
would actually
struggle to scale?
TED KRAUS: Yeah.
So most companies hit
roadblocks as they grow.
Most tech companies do.
It might be because they
don't have the right sales
and marketing team.
It might be because
they don't know
what to do from a
marketing standpoint.
It may be because they
were unable to raise money.
Most of the time, if
the company is not
able to have revenue
coming in the door,
or if they have some type
of social app or something
like this where
they need to have
millions and millions
of users, that would
be the traction in that case.
We'd come in, and we
help them figure out
what they need to do
to get that traction
to hit those growth
numbers, and then to scale
through that inflection point.
DAN FELD: I see.
And on this point, we have
a lot of entrepreneurs
that are asking themselves,
how do we get funded?
And perhaps they see
themselves fit to your bill
and to the way you
look at startups.
So what's the best
way to reach you?
What's the best way to get
you to fund their startup?
TED KRAUS: Absolutely.
So the best way
to get in contact
with a VC or an investor is
through a trusted intermediary.
So someone that you know,
that knows them as well-- they
make the connection.
There needs to be
a bridge there.
We get a lot of blind emails.
And it's very difficult for
us to meet with everybody
that we see.
So it helps a lot, if you
want to get in touch with us
or any other investor, to be
introduced through someone
that they know as well.
If you want to raise money, the
biggest thing you need to do
is have good traction.
That's by far and away the
best thing that you can do.
Have really, really strong KPIs,
Key Performance Indicators.
I'm a big fan of
actually making money.
I think that it's great to
have an application that has
millions and millions of users.
But it's also great to have
millions of users and millions
of dollars coming in.
So I'm a big fan of revenue.
DAN FELD: So the answer is both.
TED KRAUS: Both, yeah.
I want to see money,
and I want to see users.
That's what I want to see.
DAN FELD: Absolutely.
When you look at
the first meeting
with a founder or
entrepreneur with you,
and assuming that he sees
himself as ready for what you
are looking for, how
would the first meeting--
how a successful
meeting would look like?
TED KRAUS: Usually, we
know in the first 60
seconds whether or
not the founding team
and the founder, the person
that we're speaking with,
is fundable.
We know if they have
the confidence that's
needed to succeed as a
founder, as an entrepreneur.
We usually know beforehand
if their product is good.
So we know pretty
fast whether or not
we're going to make an
investment and do the deal.
DAN FELD: So once the meeting
actually was scheduled,
there is a high--
it's pre-qualified.
TED KRAUS: Yeah.
DAN FELD: You know a lot of
things about the founder.
TED KRAUS: So if you get a
meeting with the investor
or with anyone, they have done a
little bit of diligence on you.
They know what you're going to
come and talk to them about.
DAN FELD: So what's left?
What do I need to do?
How do I nail the 30%
that is left for me
to do at the first meeting?
TED KRAUS: I have a very
clear well-defined ask.
It's very important.
Don't go in into any meeting
and not have an agenda.
Have a very clear ask.
Have a plan.
If the person
you're meeting with
wants to know how you're
going to get from A to B,
if they invest $1
million in you,
have a plan, and
very explicitly state
how you're going
to use the money.
What's the use of funds?
Have the ask.
Have the deal terms
in your head so you
don't have to say, oh, let
me call my CFO or my attorney
and remind me of what
the deal terms are.
Know all of these
things-- top of the mind.
DAN FELD: Let me add
that in many cases, when
you ask, how can I help you,
the answer is not clear.
People sometimes
don't come ready--
TED KRAUS: Exactly.
DAN FELD: --just just to
answer a simple question--
how can I help you?
TED KRAUS: Yes.
DAN FELD: And sometimes,
they're missing the opportunity
right there.
TED KRAUS: Exactly.
Nobody wants to waste time.
And so you need to know that.
You don't want me saying,
what can I do for you?
DAN FELD: Yeah.
So Ted, perhaps a
little bit about you--
how did you get to work
as a venture capitalist?
And perhaps a little bit about
your professional background.
TED KRAUS: Absolutely.
I started my career in Los
Angeles at Tech Coast Angels.
I was an analyst there
for a number of years.
I started a company
that was funded.
And then I ended up
moving to the east coast
and I lived very
near Duke University
in Durham, North
Carolina for a few years.
And I worked at a great
fund there called Eight
Rivers Capital.
We commercialized several
amazing technologies.
And then in 2013, I wanted
to come back to California.
And I had the opportunity
to move back here and start
working with Tech-Rx.
I really like the model
that Tech-Rx uses.
It fills a gap in the
venture ecosystem here,
which is companies
that are struggling.
They're great technologies.
They're great products.
But we don't want to see
them evaporate and go away.
And we can all think of these.
Maybe there was an
application that you used
or there was a really
wonderful product that
was hot for a period
of time, and then
it just kind of
dissolved and went away.
Maybe there was something
they could have done
to prevent that from happening.
And so we try to work with
a few companies a year.
We're very hands on.
It lets me--
basically, my role is
I get to be an investor and
an operator in a company,
in startups, at the same time.
It's a dream for me
to be able to do that.
And it's a really
wonderful thing that we do.
DAN FELD: Wonderful.
And last question-- what
would be the Google product
that you most use or like?
TED KRAUS: I love all
the Google products.
My favorite products
are-- I like Google Maps.
I like Inbox on my phone.
I like Calendar on my phone.
The new apps that
have come out-- I'm
a huge fan of Google Drive,
Documents, and Sheets.
I use them for team
development whenever
we have anything we want to
do on Sheets or Google Drive,
on Docs.
And also, the one product that
I'm the most excited about
to come out at
Google is definitely
the self-driving car.
I can't wait.
I see them all over the place.
And I'm very excited
about that product.
DAN FELD: We share the feeling.
Thank you very much, Ted.
TED KRAUS: Excellent.
Thank you.
DAN FELD: And thank you
very much for watching.